STRUGGLING.
THIS IS A VERY TIGHT-KNIT
COMMUNITY IN PARKLAND.
THANK YOU BOTH.
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY TED
WILLIAMS.
WE SAW THE POLICE, THE SHERIFF,
THE FBI.
WE SEE FIRST RESPONDERS.
YOU SEE EVERYBODY, THE
SUPERINTENDENT, THE GOVERNOR,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, EVERYBODY
ALL HANDS ON DECK TODAY.
I WAS WATCHING THIS ALL UNFOLD
LIVE WHEN I WAS ON MY RADIO SHOW
TODAY AND JUST HOW AMAZING THESE
PEOPLE ARE.
BUT IT’S AFTER THE FACT.
DO WE NEED TO RECONSIDER SAFETY
FOR THESE SCHOOLS?
>> WELL, YEAH, I THINK WE DO.
BUT LET ME SAY, SEAN, FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE INTERVIEW YOU
JUST HAD WITH THOSE TWO YOUNG
WOMEN.
WE SAW THE BEST OF AMERICA IN
THOSE TWO YOUNG WOMEN.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS GUY
NICOLAS CRUZ, YOU’RE SEEING, AS
THE GOVERNOR SAID, PURE EVIL.
THIS WAS A COLD-BLOODED,
CALCULATED, CARRIED-OUT CARNAGE
MASSACRE.
AND WE DO HAVE TO START
RETHINKING HOW WE HAVE GUARDS
AND SECURITY IN THESE VARIOUS
SCHOOLS.
THE SAD COMMENTARY, SAWN  --
SEAN, IS WE CANNOT MAKE OUR
SCHOOLS A PRISON.
WE DID HAVE A GUARD THERE.
BUT IF SOMEBODY IS HELLBENT ON
GOING IN A SCHOOL AND KILLING
YOUNG PEOPLE, 12 OF THESE
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DEAD
TONIGHT.
THIS IS A TRAGEDY, SEAN, IN AND
OF ITSELF.
>> THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
I KNOW I’M KNOWN FOR TALKING
POLITICS ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS NOT POLITICAL.
I DON’T THINK IT IS SOMETHING
THAT MOST PEOPLE WOULD DISAGREE
WITH.
AND MANNY, I’LL THROW THIS TO
YOU.
IF YOU’RE IN ANY ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING -- IN THIS CASE IT’S A
SCHOOL.
IT SEEMS THERE’S GOT TO BE
GREATER ORDER IN TERMS OF
MONITORING WHO’S GETTING INTO
THESE SCHOOLS.
I KNOW SCHOOLS THAT MONITOR AND
CONTROL WHO GETS INTO THEM.
IT CAN BE DONE AND IT CAN BE
DONE FAIRLY EASILY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY -- AND THEY
DID HAVE A GUARD.
BUT A SCHOOL THIS BIG WITH 3200
STUDENTS AND MULTIPLE BUILDINGS,
IT SEEMS TO ME YOU NEED A FEW
PEOPLE IN EACH BUILDING.
RETIRED MILITARY, RETIRED
POLICE.
AND I WOULD THINK OVER TIME THAT
FAMILIES -- WE’RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT ALL THAT MUCH MONEY AT THE
END OF THE DAY IF EACH DISTRICT
IS PAYING FOR THAT SECURITY.
EVERY BUILDINGS I WALK INTO IN
NEW YORK CITY, EVERY SINGLE
BUILDING, IF I DON’T HAVE AN ID,
I WILL GO THROUGH SECURITY.
AND IF I DON’T HAVE A CLEARANCE,
I’M NOT GETTING IN.
AND IF WE CAN DO IT IN EVERY
BUILDING IN NEW YORK POST-9/11,
I WOULD THINK WE CAN DO IT IN
EVERY SCHOOL IN AMERICA IF WE
WANT TO.
>> THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
GUNS.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH PROTECTING
OUR CHILDREN.
I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU IN
TERMS OF HAVING FORMER MILITARY
AND/OR FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ONE WAY TO DO IT IS TO PERHAPS
FEDERALIZE IT.
SO THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
CONGRESS MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
AND MOVING FORWARD SET UP A
FEDERAL SYSTEM TO PROTECT OUR
SCHOOLS, BECAUSE SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HONESTLY DON’T HAVE
THE BUDGET FOR IT OR MAY NOT BE
WILLING TO RAISE TAXES FOR IT,
EVEN THOUGH IT’S A NECESSARY
THING.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE’VE
GOT TO PUT A PRICE -- I REMEMBER
THE MOVIE YEARS AGO "LEAN ON
ME."
IT WAS ABOUT THE PRINCIPAL JOE
CLARK.
HE GOT IN TROUBLE BECAUSE HE
CHAINED THE SCHOOL DOOR SHUT.
THAT’S NOT NECESSARILY THE
ANSWER.
THERE SHOULD BE VERY SPECIFIC
ENTRY POINTS AND OTHER ENTRY
POINTS SHOULD BE CLOSED OFF.
BUT BEYOND THAT -- AND LOOK, I
DON’T KNOW IF IT WOULD BE
APPLICABLE IN THIS SITUATION.
BUT I’VE GOT TO BELIEVE IN SOME
SITUATIONS THAT IF YOU HAVE
FIRST-LINE DEFENDERS THERE,
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRAINED, RETIRED
MILITARY, RETIRED POLICE, THAT
THEY’RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO AT
LEAST HOLD OFF FOR THE FIVE
MINUTES.
THE POLICE GOT THERE.
THE SHERIFF GOT THERE.
THEY GOT THERE AS FAST AS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
SWAT TEAM WAS THERE.
FIRST RESPONDERS WERE THERE.
EVERYONE DID THEIR JOB TODAY AND
DID IT SO WELL.
BUT I’M JUST THINKING FOR THE
LONG TERM, WE’VE GOT TO SECURE
THESE SCHOOLS.
AGAIN, IT’S NOT ABOUT GUNS.
IT’S SECURE THE SCHOOLS.
>> 100%.
>> I’VE GOT TO TELL BOTH YOU
GUYS, I DISAGREE.
IT IS ALSO ABOUT GUNS.
IF YOU PUT A SECURITY GUARD IN
WITH A POP GUN IN ONE OF THESE
SCHOOLS AND YOU’VE GOT A GUY
COME IN WITH AN AR-15 RIFLE --
>>I’M TALKING ABOUT ARMED
FORMER MILITARY AND ARMED FORMER
POLICE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WE TRUST.
THOSE RETIRED MILITARY AND
POLICE WOULD BECOME THE BEST
FRIENDS OF THE STUDENTS OVER
TIME.
THEY GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
IT WOULD BE GOOD ALL THE WAY
AROUND FOR EVERYBODY.
WE CAN SECURE ANYTHING WE WANT
TO SECURE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
NOBODY’S GOING TO CONVINCE ME
OTHERWISE.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE.
SO GOING BACK TO FORMER
MILITARY, FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS AN ADDED BENEFIT, GOING BACK
TO YOUR WIN-WIN, NOW YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO’S BEEN TRAINED.
AND IF THERE’S OTHER THINGS
GOING ON IN THE SCHOOL, THIS IS
A TRAINED PROFESSIONAL THAT CAN
DEAL WITH THAT, IDENTIFY IT,
INVESTIGATE IT AND DEAL WITH IT.
SO THAT’S AN ADDED BENEFIT OF
HAVING SOMEBODY OF THAT CALIBER
THERE.
BUT IT HAS TO BE FUNDED.
AND IT HAS TO BE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WHERE WE AS A
NATION SAY ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO
FUND THIS JUST PERHAPS, LIKE I
MENTIONED, THE TSA PROGRAM.
>> I WAS NOT TALKING ABOUT
UNARMED FORMER RETIRED MILITARY
POLICE.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO BE SHOWING --
THEY COULD OBVIOUSLY HAVE IT
CONCEALED.
BUT THEY CERTAINLY WOULD BE THE
FRONT LINE OF DEFENSE.
BUT I DO BELIEVE SECURING THOSE
DOORS.
NOBODY THAT IS EXPELLED FROM THE
SCHOOL SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT SCHOOL EVER.
THE OTHER THING IS PAYING
ATTENTION TO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OR DISGRUNTLED KIDS OR
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES, LOOKING AT
THE SOCIAL MEDIA FOOTPRINT OF A
KID YOU THROW OUT OF SCHOOL.
APPARENTLY, WE’RE LEARNING WE
COULD HAVE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THIS KID.
AND THAT HAPPENS AFTER ALMOST
EVERY SHOOTING.
PEOPLE ARE TELEGRAPHING WHERE
THEY’RE HEADED.
>> YOU’RE RIGHT.
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING, YOU NEED
TO SAY SOMETHING.
AND WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH OF
THAT.
BUT I WAS ALSO HAPPY, I MUST SAY
-- AND I’M USING THE WORD HAPPY
AND ENCOURAGED ABOUT WHAT PAM
BONDI, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
THERE AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
DEATH PENALTY.
WHEN YOU PUT GAS MASKS ON, WHEN
YOU PUT SMOKE BOMBS, YOU GO IN A
SCHOOL AND PULL AN ALARM, YOU’RE
ABLE TO SHOOT ALL THESE PEOPLE
AND THEN ABLE TO LEAVE THAT
SCHOOL AND I WANT TO FIND OUT
THAT YOU’RE MENTALLY ILL.
I HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS WHEN YOU HAVE THE